a quadratic equation is an equation that
has a variable to the second degree
right so this is a quadratic and you can
see this is set equal to zero we're
trying to solve for X and normally what
we would do is we just go ahead and use
our quadratic formula here you can see x
equals negative b plus or minus the
square root of b squared minus 4ac all
over 2a but what we're going to do is
we're going to show you how you can get
from this equation to this equation by
completing the square so the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
subtract C from both sides of this
equation so that gives us ax squared
plus BX equals negative C now because we
have a leading coefficient of a what I'm
going to do is I'm going to divide the
left and the right sides of the equation
by a to keep it balanced okay so if we
do that these are going to cancel one
another out we're left with x squared
plus B over a times x equals negative C
over a now we're going to complete the
square at this point and the way we do
that is we take half of this middle
coefficient so this is going to be like
a trinomial were to take half of this
middle coefficient the number in front
of the X and we're going to square it so
half of B over a that's multiplying by
one half and we're going to square that
so that's going to give us B over 2a of
the quantity squared which is B squared
over 4a squared okay so I'm just
squaring the numerator and squaring the
denominator and so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to add that to both sides
of the equation to keep it balanced so B
squared over 4a squared okay so you're
with me so far
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to factor this trinomial the way
we've set it up is it's going to be a
perfect square so it's going to be X
plus B over 2a the quantity squared
equals now over here to combine these
we're gonna have to get common
denominator so I'm gonna have to
multiply the numerator and the
denominator of this fraction by 4a so we
get the common denominator of 4a squared
so that's going to give us 4a squared
this is going to be B squared for this
fraction and this is going to be a
negative 4ac for this fraction okay now
we're going to take the square root of
both sides okay and the square and the
square root those cancel each other out
so we just have X plus B over 2a equals
now remember when you take the square to
both sides of the equation you get plus
or minus
the square root of b squared minus 4ac
all divided by now the square root of 4a
squared is just 2a so we can simplify
that part of the square root and then
the last part here is we're just going
to subtract B over 2a from both sides of
the equation okay and so that's going to
give us x equals negative B over 2a plus
or minus the square root of b squared
minus 4ac all over 2a and then we can
combine these together into one fraction
because they have a common denominator
negative b plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus 4ac all over 2a so
that's it so that's how you would drive
the quadratic formula by completing the
square
when you're given a quadratic equation
like that so I hope this helps you
understand how to work with this a
little bit better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to seeing you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon